hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot
I'm Mike McCarty I recently got the
chance to play through a few hours of
the outer world the upcoming obsidian
open-world RPG as did my friend Dan
Reicher I did from Giant Bomb
that's me hi friends of the site so we
thought we'd get together and talk about
what we played at the time recording we
played about two weeks ago but we've
been running through some things you saw
cuz there was a lot to the demo we got
to play like an intro a couple of hours
which we can't technically talk about
specifically now right we like created
characters yeah and I also literally
want to spoil the beginning like right
what you're gonna see at the beginning
but we did get to play two hours on this
planet called monarch the thing that
stuck out to me and this is the thing
that you remembered even though we
played two weeks ago is like it combats
really good
yeah so that's the thing is that
obviously there's comparisons to fallout
that are gonna happen here because the
pedigree and just the genre I never knew
Vegas I mean they made yeah yeah but I
mean you look at every one of these
pathetic games and the thing everyone
says about all the recent ones it's like
I'm still kind of that janky old feelin
engine that we've had since God knows
when of course they've added to it and
stuff but it still feels like the very
stiff engine and by the time Fallout 4
came out I think people were done with
that and so we're all waiting and hoping
that like oh Elder Scrolls 6 or
something is gonna be like it's gonna
feel modern and new but I feel like the
outer worlds was kind of the first time
I had that feeling of like oh this is
that type of game this is very much that
but there's the style of game it just
feels good and it feels like a game that
should exist in 2019
yeah it's cuz that's there's always that
argument between is Bethesda bgs is
fallout 3 better or obsidians New Vegas
which they are similar structurally but
neither of them had we were saying like
the combat is fine if not even mediocre
and in the outer worlds I actually was
going out of my way to get into combat
it was fluid I mean I played mouse and
keyboard but I've tried controller it
felt awesome but like like I think like
in the past they've kind of relied on
vats they're like the players I don't
want to use vats so we don't have to
really make the shooting as good fallout
4 like you said they kind of improved on
and I realized those are different
Studios but they're very much in the
same vein of those open-world sandbox
games and now the combats just like
really smooth and like stealth was great
and getting at the different situations
just felt natural as hell yeah
babs was a really cool gimmick I really
liked the way it worked and you
technically could do this stuff where
you're just going around and just aiming
live shooting and everything but that
never felt great whereas this felt like
if this was just a first-person shooter
it would have felt like totally fine
like I'm not going to say it's like the
best controlling thing in the world but
I could play a whole game with these
controls basically and it does have
those options for stealth it's got all
the different ways you can spec your
character so you can approach all these
situations in different ways I felt that
even without like vats I didn't need a
gimmick for the combat here I could just
run around and shoot things the way I
want to because they do have like a
bullet tiny thing and you're kind of
seeing it right now where I was using
like a DMR kind of marksman rifle for
most the time and you get to slow it
down and if you're watching the clip
that I think you are then
it's more it's like I'm getting
headshots really easily I mean again it
is mouse and keyboard but there's no
problem like I'm going in I'm killing
like one two three and it's it's no
problem at all and it feels great right
that you're talking with that focus
meter yang where you could actually like
see like parts of armor or parts of a
beast or something
yeah and I also loved the way they do
the companion stuff it's very simple in
that like the whole time I was playing I
had two companions and each of them had
like one attack that I could trigger
with left or right on the d-pad and so
it's not like I was doing a bunch of
like you know I'm freezing I'm like okay
you did this not strategic really it's
just like okay there's a big scorpion
weird thing over here I'll look at that
I'll tap left somebody will come up with
a giant electric hammer and mess it up
while I deal with the stuff over here I
thought that worked really well and the
cooldown is pretty short so you can do
it pretty frequently oh yeah definitely
I'm like they were doing pretty good
damage too oh yeah like I do the minigun
girl but like yes but you just thing out
I'd followed her quest most the time
that's actually kind of one thing like
two things there's that stat leadership
which at the beginning of my demos like
I wonder how that affects things that my
assumption was just like it'll buff
characters around me and I was like oh
yeah like they're really aiming to kind
of make companions a key pillar of this
game because in past you know but says
the slash obsidian open-world sandbox
games companions were nice to have and
they develop their own cult fandoms but
they were so annoying that you just put
yeah they were tough on exactly they
were pack mules yeah but now at the the
leadership skill like apparently like
just buff those abilities so you could
just kind of sit back and be more of
like a it's not a strategy game but you
can kind of just give commands more
often and like just from the cool stuff
I saw with the minigun woman and the
electric hammer a woman like it just
seems I can't wait to see what other
kind of fighters I'll be able to command
yeah and I also can't wait to see like
the choices you're gonna be able to make
I know this is like a scaled-back
version they said like what like more
like 20 hours
yeah the BIG's the big but those the
games but in talking to that first
companion the one where what was your
like in a corporation and the CEO or
something was saying like oh you need to
go turn off their power or something
like that you have to go to this this
group or whatever then you talk to your
companion and she's right I talk to the
mayor oldest the the kind of
self-proclaimed mayor and then you found
out she's from the village or something
or she sympathizes with them yeah you
talk to her okay they're good people you
know it's they're having a tough time
and so like it made me wonder if we're
gonna have like was it fallout 3 with
the like Megaton yeah yeah you could you
know big decisions like that I got the
sense that we're gonna see some of that
stuff here you and Marauder
me and my sunshine that's my gun if you
were wondering we don't take kindly a
coherent enough response I reckon I was
following that but then I talked to my
companion and she essentially she's like
yeah like some graves of my old friends
are nearby if you get the chance and be
nice to go visit them
I hear people kind of like loot them now
like grave robbers so if we could you
know that mop that'd be great and then I
was like I'm just gonna follow that and
see how it goes and then I went through
these winding caves and I finally ended
up there and that was my demo and I'm
pretty sure the guy next to me and the
woman next to me just did completely
different things but that was a
full-fledged to our companion quest
which could have taken me longer if I
was like exploring everything I wanted
to and I was like we were exploring a
good deal but I was also trying to see
as much as I could before the demo like
all in all like you said this is a more
of a parrot back take on that kind of
game maybe like now that obsidian is
kind of under Microsoft and they have a
little more money you like to think
maybe down the road they'll make a
bigger thing like this but I
all in all I'm excited after everything
I saw yeah and I also really just kind
of like the tone and feel of it or it's
like you know we've played so many of
these like post-apocalyptic Brown
whatever or Fallout games and this one
it's very bright and very colorful and
it's doing this thing where it's like
it's not steampunk because you know
steampunks been so overdone to which is
I'm glad it's not steampunk it is that
like old you know 5060 sci-fi stuff or
it's these guns that look really sleek
and then weird rings on them and it's uh
it's kind of a underused
aesthetic I think and I think it yeah
super works in this game and I never
really took to like Golden Age stuff but
I do like how it's almost combining
sci-fi with art deco kind of okay not
like I'm not a Bioshock way but I really
do enjoy it it's very colorful as you've
seen from the footage you're watching
it's it's it looks really like a lot of
bulbous mushrooms and weird growths
everywhere and these critters and
everything yeah and I shot most of those
animals but they were like it seemed
like I wanted to get off that planet and
just to see what else there is but yeah
like oh and oh I'm super excited after I
played it because again the combats not
like just there and it doesn't need a
crutch it kind of is its own thing and I
was like fine just going into stealth
and taking out this little plan to camp
it was great and I'm looking forward to
it
yeah I I came away from that there
very excited to play the full game so
the outer worlds releases on October
25th for ps4 Xbox one and PC and as of
yesterday apparently also unintended so
if you're solely on Nintendo you can
look forward to that we do have an
article from Phil horn sha that is up on
GameSpot calm it's more deep dive he
talks a lot more about the comedy just a
lot of mechanics so you can go read that
as well other than that we will see you
in up to October 23rd thanks
[Music]